some of its been spectacular some of
it's been math and some of it's been
well pretty awful still we can't help
but love each and every iteration of our
friendly neighborhood spider-man that
said we're breaking down every one of
Spidey's flicks ranked worse the best of
course let's just get this out of the
way
spider-man three features one of the
silliest plot points in a franchise full
of them and that's the way the Venom
symbiote attaches itself to Parker in
case you've forgotten lucky you it falls
out of space and just up and crawls to
his scooter obviously the comic book
version wouldn't be a viable option
since it would involve a massive Super
Bureau crossover but considering Harry
Osborn had just taken over his father's
science-based corporation it seems like
there were plenty of more believable
ways to introduce the insidious oil
slick I need to talk to you explain
things tell us my father raised him from
the dead
while the overcrowding of villains
including Sandman venom and the lazily
named new Goblin was a chief complaint
perhaps the worst crime spider-man three
committed was retconning the death of
peter's uncle toward the end of the film
we learned it was actually Flint Marko
and not that Rando Parker let passed him
in spider-man who murdered Ben Parker
one of the things that makes spider-man
stand apart from the other heroes is
that he actually is partially to blame
for the traumatic death he tortures
himself over pulling out the rug from
under that makes him a very different
dude like spider-man 3 director Marc
Webb's second amazing spider-man entry
had too many bad guys
there was electro Green Goblin and the
Rhino kind of the encounter spider-man
earlier in the film is a gunman but
doesn't show up as the Rhino literally
until the last few minutes rather than
the Hulk sized baddie from the comics
he's just a dude in a big mech suit and
the movie ends abruptly during his
battle with spider-man it's a pretty
anticlimactic moment to say the least
arguably it was for the best
if amazing spider-man 2 hadn't been a
failure Sony probably wouldn't have been
as receptive to the idea of partnering
with Marvel Studios and letting old
webhead
come home and finally join the MCU you
can't say Andrew Garfield's first shot
is spite he received universal praise
but it was certainly better received
than its sequel amazing spider-man
showed up five years after Tobey Maguire
hung up the tights and while it was okay
it never quite managed to escape the
strangeness of a franchise rebooted
while its predecessor was still
relatively fresh in the cultures
collective mind amazing spider-man had
to walk a tightrope but being different
enough from the Tobey Maguire films that
had distinguished itself but not so
different that it became unrecognizable
you can argue back and forth about
whether Garfield or McGuire was better
his old webhead but there was at least
one way in which Garfield's betrayal
simply was superior and there's no
argument he was funny I'm gonna throw
you out the window now
now director Sam Raimi spider-man films
had a lot of humor but McGuire's Peter
Parker was never funny himself at least
not intentionally one of Spidey's
defining characteristics is his
wisecracking in the face of danger
that was something Garfield delivered on
and it went a long way toward making
amazing spider-man feel much more like
an echo of the comics with the glut of
superhero movies that we see today it's
easy to forget how important the first
spider-man was to everything that
followed x-men had been released two
years before and Blade 2 years before
that but blade was a grittier more
violent superhero than the x-men had a
cool rebel vibe unique to the franchise
and of course they were all dressed in
black leather spider-man was the first
21st century superhero movie success to
feature a more traditional crime
fighting hero and bright red and blue
Peter Parker's coming-of-age story
proved that the less edgy superheroes
like Iron Man Thor and Captain America
could thrive on the big screen under the
right direction it was by no means
perfect but it created a framework for
every spider-man movie that followed
even its mistake served to improve all
the superhero movies that came after
perhaps the biggest fault of the
spider-man is that the filmmakers went
out of their way to cast the brilliant
Willem Dafoe and then stuck him at a
green plastic helmet that made him look
like a Power Rangers villain every time
you notice how dynamic Ryan Reynolds
mask is in Deadpool or its sequel those
are lessons learned from spider-man
don't doubt it for a second Tom Holland
is spider-man with a snarky confidence
and his heroic abilities contrasted with
his awkward insecurities and his
desperate need to please Tony Stark he's
got a certain indefinable quality that
neither of his fellow Peter Parker
actors could truly pin down so uh how
long you been here long enough to be
awkward boss wants to see it in the
toilet no he's upstate by dialing back
Parker's age we get a much better look
at what it's like for Peter to be a
superhero and a teenager and unlike the
Maguire Parker who was almost completely
friendless Pollan has his own small
circle of outcasts but the fact that he
has friends highlights exactly how alone
is when he puts on the suit
same can be said of Iron Man's
involvement in the story knowing that
Tom Hollands Spidey's in the same world
as Thor and Captain America makes it
feel that much more precarious for the
young hero when he's the only one trying
to take down Michael Keaton's
brilliantly acted vulture even though
it's all of those other hero stuff the
guy's trying to steal before Tom
Hiddleston want audiences hearts is
low-key few movie super villains were
simultaneously as ruthless brutal and
yet somehow sympathetic as Alfred Molina
playing Otto Octavius aka Doctor Octopus
visually he managed to be both more
human than Willem Dafoe's Green Goblin
and more menacing while it may be a
little choppy compared to today's
effects in 2004 the extended battle
between Doc Ock and Spidey on a moving
train was intense and amazing as a
middle chapter spider-man 2 hit all the
right notes the conflict between the
life Peter wants spanned the one his
life as a hero demands the revelations
Harry Osborn comes to about his best
friend and his father and the set up for
the next chapter were executed perfectly
spider-man 2 felt like a movie made just
to show everyone else exactly what a
superhero movie could be there may be a
better spider-man movie than spider-man
into the spider verse but if so it was
released in another universe there are a
lot of differences between into the
spider verse and the 2014 comic book
event it was loosely based upon one
thing it had in common was the cast of
parallel reality spider heroes and
another was the delight it took in the
medium of comics and its long history
there's a cartoon Pig spider-ham
the anime manga inspired SPDR
spider-gwen and of course Nicolas Cage
is spider-man noir unburdened from
live-action and from the continuity
restraints of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe into the spider verse is
action-packed hilarious and kid-friendly
while still complex and emotionally
charged enough for adults to enjoy it
introduced diversity to a franchise
without seeming like it was really
trying to do that it feels as natural as
Spidey swinging from one building to the
next check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]